if i can save everyone on planet earth  10 minutes every day i will be a  billionaire think about that and so the  way to deconstruct that is to think what  is something that lots of people spend  time on is there a way that i can  automate this and again zero incremental  cost which means this is often going to  be some sort of technology or software  solution what did google do gave  everyone time back they monetized  through advertising but everyone was  looking for something normally it would  take longer to look for something and  then they consolidated in one place they  saved everyone time you can capture an  entire marketplace by giving them time  back